what's been the best day so far in your
[Music]
everything else career I think it's this
think I'm peeking right now now I'm just
sucking up the day I interviewed Barack
Obama basically was trying to encourage
young voters to get out there and vote
and to use their voice and be able to
exercise their right from the democracy
that we have and at the very end of the
video I actually voted you can't legally
show it on camera but I actually voted
on my absentee ballot and was super
excited I was wearing like American
boxers and had an American bandana tied
around my head and that's in the same
video as Barack Obama it's me in boxers
I originally started uploading videos on
vine recipes baby my first clip on vine
I think I was 18 years old it was just
me with my phone in my car just like
dancing along or talking or making a
joke and I eventually realized that I
could talk for much longer than that as
you can see in this interview and I can
go on and on and on so I transitioned
over into YouTube and started making
videos there then it transitioned I kind
of evolved and started creating
characters and started creating sketches
and started talking about relatable
topics for girls and guys so it just
became a mishmash of things what's the
best piece of advice you've ever
received oh I actually just read
something today that wasn't a fart that
was my shoe can I am trying to grab my
could you okay and he you're gonna ask
me for this so I have a screenshot of my
phone it was one of the best ways I know
to get something I want or need is to
give some of it away and I think that's
the best thing to live by you have to be
generous and grateful for what you have
in order to get exactly what you want
and I've I feel like that's something
that I strive to do in my work on
YouTube and even in interviews and among
any social interaction that I've ever
had with any person ever I try to be my
very best and try to be happy and try to
share my positive spirit with others and
I think that Karma's been good to me
thanks for
[Music]
YouTube kind of just like open the door
of opportunities for me which was
incredible like it's such a blessing to
be able to say that because of YouTube I
started acting and because of YouTube I
started hosting I'm doing exactly what I
love and I define success by my health
and my happiness so that I think
determines how good you can be at your
job is making sure that your mental
health is intact and also that you're
happy doing what you're doing
[Music]